david our state continues to seek
volunteers with a background
in the medical or science fields to
assist in the pandemic
and as the i-team's vanessa murphy shows
us staffing
is an issue inside hospitals
some hospital reps tell me health care
workers are doing
overtime and hospitals are actively
trying to find
more workers there are several issues
here this is a nationwide surge of
covet-19
cases there's a nationwide shortage of
health care workers
and nevada has to compete for those
workers i reached out to
hospitals in southern nevada a
spokeswoman for mountain view hospital
says they're doing everything they can
to recruit new nurses and clinical staff
they're sourcing additional nurses
through external
agencies current ratios are within
guidelines
and bonuses are offered to staff in high
need areas for
extra shifts worked as well as sign-on
bonuses
a spokesman for umc says they're well
staffed thanks to nurses and
other staff working overtime and a
spokesman for dignity health says
hospitals are constantly adjusting staff
and they've gone to great lengths to
hire more staffing including
traveling nurses to care for a surge in
patients
the nevada hospital association does not
provide numbers for specific
hospitals we've asked to find out just
how severe
any staffing shortages may be the
association releases general numbers by
county
so for example right now it reports that
81 percent of staffed hospital beds in
clark county
are full as i mentioned there's a big
need for nurses
and also lab techs to help process the
covid19
tests which takes training and
certification
vanessa murphy 8 news now